the uncertainty on the global markets
over Banks this morning Switzerland's
Central Bank is making an extraordinary
move to restore confidence throwing a
Lifeline to Credit Suisse Bank Global
Investment Bank Credit Suisse is now
breathing a sigh of relief after
suffering a mass Exodus of investors a
166 year old institution will borrow up
to 54 billion dollars from the Swiss
National Bank holstering confidence as
fears grow about the banking system's
resilience the belated company Credit
Suisse will borrow 81 billion dollars
from Switzerland's Central Bank credit
Swiss hopes the intervention will
reassure investors the company has
enough money to stay afloat after a
cheers nosed of more than 24 percent
[Music]
for silvergate Bank collapsed then
Silicon Valley been collapsed then
Senator Ben collapsed just two days
later and now Credit Suisse is next
Credit Suisse the 167 year old bank and
the second largest lender in Switzerland
is in deep trouble Credit Suisse is huge
they have half a trillion dollars in
assets and the bank ranks among the
world's largest wealth managers and
crucially it is one of 30 Global
systematically important Banks whose
failure would cause ripples through the
entire Financial system and right now
it's on the verge of imploding shares
and credits we spell 24 on Friday after
it said it found weakness in its
financial reporting it's running out of
money and if someone doesn't save them
they're gonna take the rest of us down
with them Bankers wrecked the world
during the 2008 financial crisis and now
it looks like it's all happening again
stay dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
and by the way if you like videos like
this then you are going to love our
video on the truth behind climate change
and how the elite push climate change
because it's a great way to keep poor
Nations poor by suffocating them with
carbon emission limits so they keep
making our pots and pans and you can
watch it right now by clicking the card
on the top right corner obviously this
video wouldn't fly publicly so it's part
of our YouTube membership where we post
our more spicy videos that will never be
released publicly there's one coming out
around once a month including our
upcoming one on how Vice President Dick
Cheney got rich off of the Iraq War so
click the card on the top right corner
to watch the climate change one right
now or click that join button below now
back to the banking crisis
Credit Suisse isn't some new player in
the banking world this bank is nearly
200 years old and for a bank that's
nearly 200 years old one would think
that it would be pretty sound that it
would be a pretty trustworthy bank but
nope because aside from their fancy
sounding name Credit Suisse is as shady
as they come you remember that slimy
Swiss Banker in The Wolf of Wall Street
movie that let the Wolf of Wall Street
hide his money Lair yeah that's
basically Credit Suisse Credit Suisse
has been struggling for years in 2014
Credit Suisse pled guilty to federal
charges that it illegally allowed some
U.S clients to invade their taxes in
2020 the Credit Suisse CEO resigned
after two high-profile spying scandals
involving top Bank officials a year
later the collapse of the U.S hedge fund
RK goes Capital cost Credit Suisse 5.5
billion dollars and damage the bank an
independent external investigation later
found that Credit Suisse allowed rko's
Capital to take voracious and
potentially catastrophic risks that
accumulated in the U.S hedge fund
spectacular collapse but it doesn't end
there in 2022 the bank was hit by social
media speculation that it was on the
drink of collapse leading customers to
withdraw billions of dollars and just
last month credit suisse's stock plunged
to record lows after it posted its
biggest annual loss since the financial
crisis in 2008 but the scandals don't
even end there in 2022 credit suisse's
chairman resigned after being caught
breaking covet quarantine rules in both
Switzerland and the UK he said that
quote I regret that a number of my
personal actions have led to
difficulties from the bank and
compromised my ability to represent the
bank internally and externally end quote
but it turned out that this chairman got
out of Credit Suisse at the perfect time
because Credit Suisse was about to get
caught up in one of his biggest scandals
yet the Swiss Secrets leak over 18 000
bank accounts at credit Suites were
leaked by a whistleblower who said that
Swiss banking secrecy laws were immoral
regardless if you think Swiss banking
laws are immoral the league exposed
Credit Suisse for some really dark stuff
that isn't all that surprising it showed
that Credit Suisse had kept working with
clients who were involved with money
laundering human trafficking corruption
and many other serious crimes what was
credit suisse's response fonts that they
strongly rejected any allegations of
wrongdoing the main political grouping
in the European Parliament called for a
review of Switzerland's banking
practices and for the country's possible
inclusion in the eu's Dirty Money
Blacklist after lease of Credit Suisse
documents the EU was trying to go after
them but the damage the criticism's
reputation had already been done so
critic squeeze had been hammered the
past few years with scandal after
scandal after Scandal and one would
think that if you were in this position
you would clean up your act you would
stop doing Shady stuff at least until
there was less heat on you but nope
credit Swiss just kept up with all their
Shady business practices right until
their 2022 financial report was released
[Music]
on March 14th Credit Suisse revealed
their 2022 financial report and the
results were shocking Credit Suisse said
I found material weaknesses in his
financial reporting over the past two
years because of ineffective internal
controls translation Credit Suisse was
admitting that their financial data for
the past two years was unreliable which
is literally the last thing you want to
hear from a bank you keep your money at
the report also confirmed that credit
Suite suffered a huge loss from
customers withdrawing their money after
the Swiss Secrets leaked so naturally
their stock prices continue to go lower
and lower the day after the financial
report dropped Credit Suisse reached out
to their top investor to ask for some
financial help they were thinking that
hopefully if they got support from their
top investor their stock price would go
up again and people wouldn't panic and
who was their biggest shareholder the
Saudi National Bank and unfortunately
for Lum the Saudi National Bank was not
going to bail amounts the chairman of
the Saudi National Bank simply said the
answer is absolutely nuts for many
reasons what its biggest shareholder not
coming to the rescue Credit Suisse was
in big trouble 2 two major U.S banks
that tank less than a week before and
now Credit Suisse was next on The
Chopping Block so everyone started
selling their Credit Suisse stock Credit
Suisse shared slump out as much as 30 it
was the worst crash Credit Suisse has
seen since 2008 the bank Panic had
officially spread to Europe and if
critically stood any chance to make it
out alive it would need a bailout and
fast
foreign
as the stock price crashed credit
suisse's chairman came out to calm
investor spheres we have strong Capital
ratios a strong balance sheet we already
took the medicine he said but in reality
critic Swiss was probably on his last
dying breath and quite frankly it's
exactly what they deserved they deserve
to go down but if critic Swiss went down
they would take down the rest of
Europe's banks with them and Europe's
most powerful Bankers were not going to
go down with them so at the very last
minute Switzerland's Central Bank
stepped in to save the day with a 54
billion dollar bailout credits we said
early on Thursday it was taking decisive
action to strengthen its liquidity by
exercising its option to borrow from the
Swiss National Bank but the 50 billion
Swiss Francs 54 billion dollars now this
may seem unfair Credit Suisse put
themselves in this position so they
should suffer the consequences the Swiss
people shouldn't be the ones bailing
them out just like how average everyday
Americans shouldn't be the ones bailing
out Silicon Valley Bank but in reality
this is how the world works if you you
want to have the same unfair advantage
that these banks have you need to make
everyone so dependent on you you need to
make everyone so rely on you that if you
go down they all go down critic Suites
and Silicon Valley Bank didn't get
bailout because they're the good guys
they got bailed out because they put
themselves in a position where the
entire economy depends on them they
truly became too big to fail and it
looks like there's another bank
collapsing right now that's gonna get a
bailout and this bank is called First
Republic Bank and it's happening right
now in America and we're going to cover
it in tomorrow's video so click the
circle on the screen to subscribe now so
you don't miss that video in the
meantime watch our old video on the
Absurd business of banking to learn how
Banks print money out of thin air it's
an old one but it is great click the
card on the screen to watch now
foreign